Susan Daniels: it's time for work day two in the five day boot camp today we've got.
Susan Daniels: A lot of rich topics we don't have many topics, but we have a lot of rich topics we're going to be covering.
Susan Daniels: Things that we base our reputation on scope schedule cost and quality so today's a very important day I hope you have your notepads ready and you're you're laying down to learn more about project management.
Susan Daniels: couple things I like to do to start out with though today is, thank you for the very positive feedback, those of you gave on the on yesterday's.
Susan Daniels: Experience and it was very encouraging, thank you, I did notice there was a trend in the comments about the chat yes.
Susan Daniels: That chat really gets rolling and it gets kind of flying so fast that it's really not valuable anymore so i'd like to ask if we can create.
Susan Daniels: A team norm, or a group norm, that the chat will only be used for topics that are relevant to the.
Susan Daniels: conversation or lecture at the moment, or on the screen let's just use chat for instructor to student okay kind of back and forth and us talking about the content that's being presented.
Susan Daniels: That way, I can watch the answers, and I can maybe see some questions that come through, but if we have a lot of side conversations and we have exchanges of linkedin emails.
Susan Daniels: and trying to set up study groups in the middle of the chat um it's not used in the purpose it was originally intended, which is to be able to have a dialogue with the instructor instructor with the students.
Susan Daniels: i'm i'm seeing no audio but I hey guys my mentors can you guys hear me.
Susan Daniels: Okay, people can hear me thank you so.
Susan Daniels: let's keep chat clear okay just for content, relative to the material being presented.
Susan Daniels: let's use the brakes for things that are peer to peer about how to set up your study groups, maybe in your area on how to connect with each other on linkedin let's use the brakes for peer to peer conversations.
Susan Daniels: And let's use the Q amp a for technical problems if you're having technical issues, please bring it to the mentors in the Q amp a that's what they're there for one on one conversations.
Susan Daniels: direct question direct answer is that agreeable everyone can can I get a thumbs up or a yes from the as kind of buying from you guys at this is getting in control of this chat.
Susan Daniels: How right i'm getting some hallelujah is absolutely let's do that okay so that's our team norm, of how we're going to collaborate today I think we're going to be off to a good start.
Susan Daniels: I did a really good question um from my mentor group yesterday that they asked me if I would open with it so i'm i'm going to go ahead and show you the next slide so we can have a look at what we're doing today because it's going to help me answer this question.
Susan Daniels: The question was um basically can I go back over the inputs tools techniques and outputs and how the pin box six, which was so ferry focus.
Susan Daniels: On inputs tools techniques and outputs aligned to the right process, a lot of heavy remote Member, you know mode memorization.
Susan Daniels: um that's not the way this new p&p is designed Okay, so if you were coached by someone sag and you really no need to know your ITT o's which was that short acronym for inputs tools and techniques.
Susan Daniels: Well it's just not hammer down fart on that, right now, the new p&p exam is more about understanding of broader focus and.
Susan Daniels: Am I working with the process, am I, working with my people, am I really working with the environment okay.
Susan Daniels: And if i'm I figure out what domain domain i'm in, and then I try to try to figure out what am I trying to accomplish what task, am I trying to to do, and instead of thinking of things in processes you think of a more in what it would task you're trying to accomplish.
Susan Daniels: that's you see the way the curriculum is organized right by plan and manage procurement or establish project governance structure, what then you look at your tools and techniques Okay, which they call deliverables are enablers.
Susan Daniels: I wanted to kind of take the old mindset of the pen box six and go everything you may have studied and learned is still useful but that framework is no longer it is passing that.
Susan Daniels: The sixth edition is valuable for the content that it has been not for its structure it's a whole new perspective now because we're bringing in both traditional project management and the agile methodology and when the.
Susan Daniels: writers, of the seventh edition try to get these two to match they realized they didn't dovetail into each other well at all.
Susan Daniels: They threw out the old and created a new framework and that's where we are today, I hope that answered the person's questions about how do I make this you know fit the just let go the ITT ohs that's not the way the exam is structured now.
Susan Daniels: Okay i'm still seeing no sound i'm not sure why you're having no sound because i'm still coming across to the majority of people um you may want to.
Susan Daniels: Go to QA and see whether they can help you with some technical recommendations.
Susan Daniels: let's try not to do highs good mornings i'm from here in the chats let's just focus on saving the chat for dialogue between the instructor in the students peer to peer conversations are During the lunch hour or in during the breaks okay.
Susan Daniels: I do see that the recommendation for anyone experiencing sound problems, maybe to to log in through your phone okay.
Susan Daniels: um he mentors i'm seeing a question about the closed caption being available today i'm just putting that to your attention let's make sure it is available.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so with us having an understanding of how to use chat Q amp a and i'm the different frameworks let's get started on today's lesson.
Susan Daniels: managed scope okay manage scope and schedule and cost and quality are the four foundations that every project managers reputation is basically assessed on right did you deliver it on schedule on budget and give me what I asked for high.
Susan Daniels: Quality has a lot to do about giving me what I asked for and meeting my expectations.
Susan Daniels: Emily years of experience, if you have to juggle between time cost and scope.
Susan Daniels: and less otherwise clearly directed always go for scope because here's my experience and you'll find it true, and maybe I can get some some amens out there.
Susan Daniels: But people will give you more time to accomplish what it is that they need and ask for people will understand the need for more money.
Susan Daniels: If they're going to get what they need, and they asked for, but you spend their money, and you spend their time and you still you know you leave you stayed on budget and on schedule, but you didn't give them what they asked for.
Susan Daniels: it's still pretty much a fail okay so always drive for meeting expectations defining scope.
Susan Daniels: Are you using scope, in place of quality i'm seeing quality is an aspect of scope Okay, there are certain features and abilities that your product process or deliverable must have but the way you measure it meeting expectation is a quality measure OK.
Susan Daniels: OK, I got an amen about always go for meeting scope.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so Neil I wanna i'm just launch right into the scope.
Susan Daniels: we've talked about these slides before it's important to be able to match, excuse me a moment.
Susan Daniels: it's important for me to be able to match up for you to be able to match the enablers to the tasks that it is associated with.
Susan Daniels: We mentioned yesterday, the importance of creating these as flashcards right and being able to just fold down the top of what you print out and look at it and go, can I name some of the enablers for managing scope or if I see these can I recognize it and tie it back to its task.
Susan Daniels: Remember yesterday, how we talked about, you have the project implementation plan won't va plan, and it is in your mind's eye a three ring binder with multiple tabs within it will behind one of those tabs is this scope management plan.
Susan Daniels: The screen gives you an idea of what is entailed and creating a scope management plan.
Susan Daniels: But I want, I want to start out by.
Susan Daniels: Expanding on the value of having scope management plans schedule management plans cost quality procurement stakeholder communications and on we go right we have these various plans that we're going to develop.
Susan Daniels: A lot of people are ready, fire aim.
Susan Daniels: And they're making it up as they go there really isn't a plan they're figuring it out as they go even though this is somewhat or should be a predictive lifecycle project.
Susan Daniels: So the value of having the scope these individual plans is.
Susan Daniels: It is your way of telling your leadership and getting their approval on how you're going to go about doing something.
Susan Daniels: it's sort of like the plan to make the plan it is hey here are the people I am going to engage with.
Susan Daniels: This is how i'm going to collect my requirements, this is where i'm going to save my requirements, this is how i'm going to set up my configuration management system.
Susan Daniels: i'm going to create my wps which stands for work breakdown structure here's the framework, the way that i'm going to do it.
Susan Daniels: With this document that you write you have the ability to get approval of hey here's how i'm going to go out and about doing this.
Susan Daniels: Do you agree and i'm looking up line like this is my upline This is my leadership my sponsors right so here's my ideas on how I want to go about defining the scope of this project, do you agree.
Susan Daniels: Well, this empowers your senior leadership to see two things one what you're about how you're going to go about doing your work right and now they're going to be comfortable.
Susan Daniels: understanding why you're running around the company doing what you're doing and talking to who you're talking to right so know that they know that you what you intend to do.
Susan Daniels: And they're comfortable, you have a plan leaders love to know you've got a plan on what you're trying to do right, and the second thing that it's really the value add for you in developing these plans and getting them approved is that.
Susan Daniels: leadership has insights perspectives and connections that you don't have access to, and when they see how you're going to go about your your project and develop it.
Susan Daniels: Now they have the ability to go course correction, you may want to talk to this person over here in this department they're much more helpful.
Susan Daniels: More oh no, no, we don't really need to talk to that person or what they didn't tell you this divisions not involved right.
Susan Daniels: They can do course correction, they can start to clarify some of your constraints and parameters of your project so it's really why the plp for years have developed the methodology of having all these individual plans.
Susan Daniels: It gives you gives leadership and an opportunity to provide guidance and gives you the project manager the guidance, you need before before you run around and start bumping into walls and making this missteps.
Susan Daniels: just looking on scanning the.
Susan Daniels: The chat okay let's keep your your concerns your technical issues let's keep them out of the chat room keeping the chat for just course related questions and comments, please take your your technical concerns to the Q amp a.
Susan Daniels: They may be able to make recommendations I am hearing and seeing that.
Susan Daniels: logging on with your phone has been an effective solution.
Susan Daniels: One of the things that is really important to have in your scope management plan.
Susan Daniels: is starting with the end in mind you're ultimately trying to define what is success that's The goal of this scope defining scope what what does it take to get from the current state to the desired future state and how do we define success in each step along the way.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: The next few slides are really just tool after tool after tool after tool after tool that we use as project managers to be able to effectively get the information we need to clarify document and find ways to measure right that we have done it and achieved it.
Susan Daniels: Is the project implementation plan, the same as the old project management plan good question don.
Susan Daniels: If you're doing a traditional methodology, the answer is yes it's just got a new name.
Susan Daniels: But when you're bringing in agile off the project implementation plan allows us to save could have agile aspects as well, or it can be hybrid so they change the title to indicate, it can be more hybrid with agile aspects.
Susan Daniels: From the design perspective Oh, this is so nice that the chat is not screaming bye Thank you guys um let's see um, how does the scope statement differ from the vision or mission statement, or is it in some or is it some above your that's a great question Russell the vision is the overall.
Susan Daniels: What is going to do for the company right it's going to improve customer satisfaction is going to improve revenue is going to.
Susan Daniels: achieve overarching.
Susan Daniels: cost savings or an efficiency okay that's kind of the the vision.
Susan Daniels: The scope is really how we're going to do that right, what has to be built, what has to be changed, what has to be implemented, what has to happen Okay, what is needed to fill that gap from our current state to the desired future state.
Susan Daniels: wps again stands for work breakdown structure which by the way, please no on the exam they may choose not to use to spell it all the way out it's one of those.
Susan Daniels: acronyms you need to know by site, because once you're in the industry, and you are, you know got your p&p we do talk in acronyms and web is is definitely one of them racy is another one.
Susan Daniels: Vision would equal business value that's yes generally that's what the vision is what is it deliver over artillery fork scope is filling is all the requirements to get from here to there.
Susan Daniels: Okay, thank you, Brian for typing in on the definition of the scope management plan is there a question in there, OK.
Susan Daniels: not sure I understand a component of the project or program management describes.
Susan Daniels: I thought project manager kind is called the plp i'm not i'm not i'm not seeing those corollary Okay, I need to get back on track, so i'm still continue to ask your questions Okay, I really love that this that the chat is getting back under control and we're again chats only for.
Susan Daniels: lecture related questions and comments okay.
Susan Daniels: So how do we figure out everything that it takes to get from the current state to the desired future state.
Susan Daniels: Well, probably the first one we're going to do is identify who should I talk to, who are the subject matter experts okay that.
Susan Daniels: would be guides to me that would be most valuable and getting the right people in the room, so that they can articulate for me the requirements that it's going to take.
Susan Daniels: So expert judgment, it is no surprise that it comes out is top of the list of the first thing that you, you do, who do I need to go to.
Susan Daniels: Now we also as we're going through our collection of requirements and gathering of them we're going to see that there may be various solutions that are being provided.
Susan Daniels: Already, that are various approaches that can be taken to get us from here to there there isn't just a single path.
Susan Daniels: That is, you know coming to light so we're going to be very much involved in alternative analysis.
Susan Daniels: and facilitating decision making about the best alternatives to take we've seen a lot of time.
Susan Daniels: Doing group decision making facilitation, to make sure we're going the right direction, and all the choices we're making are compatible and integrate double okay.
Susan Daniels: That is a key role as a project manager that integration of the work Okay, because you are that single point all things come into you, through you, and back out through you, for the most part.
Susan Daniels: And you're the one, even if you you're not the subject matter expert on how to do it your job remains the same, to get your.
Susan Daniels: Self surrounded with the right people to evaluate that it's integrated and aligned incompatible Okay, you may need to set up a task force.
Susan Daniels: That you all of the recommendations go through, and they are the right people to go, yes, these all fit together we ask this law work Okay, if you get any like whoa this isn't a good idea, and you you're the one that goes back and re works it.
Susan Daniels: isn't a charter define what the goal is what's the relationship with web yes and charter charter is very 50,000 foot big picture, this is just coming out of getting the money you know no research is being done, not all you know.
Susan Daniels: Not a lot of deep analysis has been put into place is more the vision it's more.
Susan Daniels: What we see from here, as what we need, but no one's really at this point if the Charter writing done all the work that scope development entails the scope is really.
Susan Daniels: filling in that gap very specifically what needs to change in the system, what needs to change in the process, what new capabilities, do we need and how would we get this done what would that require okay so it's much more granular I hope that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: Susan who approves the scope management plan usually your sponsors okay that's who approves it you're you've got a collection of sponsors people that you report to.
Susan Daniels: Generally, like your governance board right, the people who have the most skin in the game, but i'll talk to you about the difference between sponsors and governance board a little later in today's on group.
Susan Daniels: discussion, but it is senior leadership and it's the people that got the money and got the accountability for this project to be done you're their their manager, but there's other people who have a lot of.
Susan Daniels: at risk to for their reputations they're the ones that are going to be your guiding lights and they're the ones that you're going to send your plans to.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: I still see another question relative about it ctos, and this is the kind of the last one i'm going to address it, because I, I need you to kind of.
Susan Daniels: Understand that everything that was in the sixth edition is still valuable.
Susan Daniels: So all those inputs tools techniques and outputs they all still exist, they all still valuable they've just been crosswalks into the the enabler slides okay.
Susan Daniels: that's what's happened they've just crosswalk them from the old framework into the new framework of tasks and they've just crosswalk them into them I hope that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: How many ways still I still address on these tools techniques and enablers probably another dozen or more, as we go through the five days.
Susan Daniels: You can find all of the guidelines with the enablers out on your low choice site under checklist.
Susan Daniels: Is the scope, then real world borders of the idea of the project in the Charter is the hypothetical Oh well done Alex gas.
Susan Daniels: On charter is still very hypothetical this is best guesses, this is still in the visioning imagineering ideation stage right, but when it comes to developing your scope, this is when reality, you know when we were trying to bring this into reality.
Susan Daniels: I think it's pretty obvious that we're going to hold a lot of meetings when we're trying to develop scope.
Susan Daniels: So what are we really trying to figure out there is a difference between project requirements and product requirements.
Susan Daniels: Okay i'll give you a moment to on to assess to read the slide.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: When you have um product requirements that's the the ultimate kind of tied up that you're trying to produce this is the the product, the end result right and it might have many features and might have many components, it might have it may be very complex or maybe very simple.
Susan Daniels: You have to go and understand what it takes to build you know design build test and deliver that.
Susan Daniels: Project requirements are things that your project team might need to be able to be effective in designing building and testing those so your project requirements might need.
Susan Daniels: conference rooms, it might need a testing environment if you're doing it, it might need a requirement of certain kinds of talent and skill sets so.
Susan Daniels: you've got to collect both okay you've got to understand what it is you're trying to build and deliver and what it is you're you're going to need to be able to do it, so when you're developing scope you're collecting all that.
Susan Daniels: i'm just pausing for you.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so we have two different methodologies so in the traditional waterfall predictive methodology we.
Susan Daniels: We put everything all those requirements that we collect, we have to organize them we can't just have them in a random list right they have to have rhyme and reason, so the way we organize them is something called a work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: And this work breakdown structure can come in a variety of formats okay.
Susan Daniels: It can be done in a simple outline like you did in high school when you had to outline a term paper you know what is the major topic, and what are the supporting.
Susan Daniels: What is the next major topic, and what are this puddings well in this case, you would say, what is the deliverable what is the component, what is the feature, what is the thing.
Susan Daniels: That observable measurable thing that i'm trying to produce right and then what are some of the activities that might take to produce it.
Susan Daniels: That activities come later when we get into scheduled development women doing work breakdown structure we take all the work and we organize it in some way in some framework.
Susan Daniels: Is there a right way or wrong way to do a work breakdown structure that question many times and this The short answer to it, which is if it's logical and someone else can follow it is good enough.
Susan Daniels: So how do you start a work breakdown structure the every project is different.
Susan Daniels: If you're doing an event, you might choose to organize your requirements and all the work that needs to be done by pre event all the work at the event, you know the work after the men.
Susan Daniels: That would be logical, you can organize it by products that are going to be impacted we're going to change the process and we're going to organize all the work by each product line that we're going to impact or you can organize it by product are by.
Susan Daniels: let's call it customer segment may be able to do our geographic region that you're going to impact, you can organize it by.
Susan Daniels: who's being impacted you can organize it by who's going to help you get it, this whole project done i'm going to organize my work breakdown structure by what I have to do with service sales facilities and finance and legal okay and HR I can organize it any way that is logical and.
Susan Daniels: reasonable and that can be followed by somebody else project management is project management is both an art and a science.
Susan Daniels: The art is that you have to figure out creative thinking of how to organize all these requirements, the sciences, how to use some of these tools that will be covering.
Susan Daniels: I see a good question coming through isn't wps like a flow chart not so much a flow chart usually is documenting a process from end to end.
Susan Daniels: Okay now if that's what you're working on, you may want to organize your work breakdown structure by each step that goes into the workflow okay of this of your arm workflow but that's not.
Susan Daniels: The only way okay work breakdown structures are really the project managers attempt to organize all the work that needs to be done.
Susan Daniels: Does the Web as creative for each team or process know you have one master work.
Susan Daniels: breakdown structure, it is all hung together all the work shows up in this work breakdown structure, because it ultimately turns into your Gantt chart or if you're in agile it'll turn into a backlog but we're not there yet.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: Let me see if there's other ones i'm.
Susan Daniels: just looking at your good questions, and I do love that the the chat is slow, so that I have a chance to read it and scan it um.
Susan Daniels: If if working on a cross functional cross divisional project can you organize the wps by work streams absolutely that is probably one of the most popular ways to do it.
Susan Daniels: it's my personal favorite because then I kind of got all the work that i'm going to need from this division of the company.
Susan Daniels: kind of all in one stream and I can organize it and control costs and scheduling all as one work stream so yeah it's very popular to do it that way, but you don't have to you can organize it by geographic location product line customer group.
Susan Daniels: Anything that makes sense, IT platform that is being you know updated.
Susan Daniels: Would it can be can be part of a wps the cam man is a.
Susan Daniels: a type of wps because you have to know what a campaign is a visualization much like a Gantt chart is, but you can't build your campaign board.
Susan Daniels: or your Gantt chart until you create a master list of all the deliverables all the work packages that have to be produced to get from here, the current state to the desired future state.
Susan Daniels: Is this hard to do, does it take time, yes it's one of the last things you do first, you have to go out and collect all your requirements right.
Susan Daniels: But the goal here, why we're starting with this slide almost at the beginning, is because you start with the end in mind right if you're going to develop develop your scope.
Susan Daniels: you've got to start with the end in mind, which is i'm ultimately trying to create a master chart or outline of all the work I have to accomplish how do I think I might want to go about organizing that now, who would I need to go talk to to help me build this and fill in all the gaps.
Susan Daniels: Okay backwards planning right start i'm so Stephen covey technique start with the end in mind i'm now switching methodologies i'm leaving leaving traditional waterfall predictive i'm moving to agile.
Susan Daniels: We do very much the same thing and trying to create the master list of all the work that is going to take to produce this product Okay, we.
Susan Daniels: Have kickoff meetings and we bring the players into the room and they start to do to write these requirements, but instead of writing them as a requirement we call them user stories okay.
Susan Daniels: These user stories are organized into a master list call it a work breakdown on my apologies called a backlog.
Susan Daniels: Now this backlog gets.
Susan Daniels: Organized prioritized and it gets organized into.
Susan Daniels: story maps Okay, but we're going to go deeper on that, when we get into agile just just please know the takeaway from now is that collecting requirements and organizing all the work is what is happening when you're managing scope work breakdown structure traditional backlog for agile.
Susan Daniels: you're ultimately going to measure whether your project is done right when you have completed all of these work packages.
Susan Daniels: Can you please review the definition of user story user story is how agile planners capture requirement, it simply says and it's got a very standardized framework of how its structured okay user stories are written this way.
Susan Daniels: A lot of things in project management, these are kind of examples of user story follows this framework.
Susan Daniels: role I as this kind of user of whatever we're building or using I in this role.
Susan Daniels: want or need and you define what the need is I needed to be able to do this okay I needed to be able to do that, so in my role I needed to be able to do this because Okay, and that is the value statement what enables me to do, or why it's a benefit.
Susan Daniels: So you collect all of these user stories, which has a parallel of a requirement in a traditional project.
Susan Daniels: And you put them in a backlog I hope that's helpful more on user stories backlog management.
Susan Daniels: story plans.
Susan Daniels: The all about master planning in agile comes on Friday.
Susan Daniels: We really go deep for hours we go deep on agile so so hang in there with me okay.
Susan Daniels: hey.
Susan Daniels: Thank you for putting definitions and that's the kind of value out of using the chat Okay, so I do appreciate you guys.
Susan Daniels: slow in the role on this chat and adding useful tips for people's notes like what page they might need to look at in the pen Bach or they might need to look in the agile God, by the way, i'm.
Susan Daniels: Brenda i'm not sure what you're referencing for us to my apologies, putting definitions is very helpful because we save all the definitions to roll during the the lunch hour.
Susan Daniels: um but fundamentally please understand that a you work breakdown structure is very much a part of your scope management plan that is where you're headed okay.
Susan Daniels: Now, when you are.
Susan Daniels: awesome.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: All right.
Susan Daniels: So when you're trying to do your scope management plan, one of the things that you want to try to negotiate, you may have started to negotiate it.
Susan Daniels: In your arm remember the Charter conversation where you want to know what authorities who's got authority and.
Susan Daniels: Who has to sign what and where do you have to go to get a thumbprint of approval and then, by the way, what authorities do I have you know kind of thing, so this is kind of a continuation now, but at a more granular level, because now we're talking about it for the project itself.
Susan Daniels: When you're trying to write your scope schedule cost budget quality, you want to start to build in tolerances.
Susan Daniels: um Does anyone want to be held to perfection.
Susan Daniels: i'm willing to bet the answer's no one right.
Susan Daniels: Well, if you only have a single budget number, a single in date Okay, a single measure for quality then you're holding yourself to perfection hey we want to pursue excellence, but we don't want to be held to perfection.
Susan Daniels: So what we're going to try to do it, and this slide if it doesn't get repeated.
Susan Daniels: It needs to be mentioned here, you almost always want to negotiate a range Okay, a plus or minus amount Okay, that you can be above or below budget and still be within tolerance okay.
Susan Daniels: And that are plus or minus one time box, for your schedule and literally mean by that.
Susan Daniels: If you're doing your master schedule and it's big and it's huge it's a construction project and it's going to take a couple years right.
Susan Daniels: Then you may be reporting on things by the week Okay, maybe even by the month it occurred by the month, but if you are working on something that's only going to last a couple of months, then you probably need to have things negotiated down to like the day.
Susan Daniels: But if you are doing a 24 hour shut down project, I mean the whole business is sat down, while this is happening right, you may be working on tolerance is a plus or minus an hour okay.
Susan Daniels: So figure out what the time box is appropriate for your project and then try to negotiate an agreement.
Susan Daniels: That you are still within operating tolerances if you are plus or minus one of those time boxes plus or minus X percent above or below budget okay all your quality measures should have a range, to the extent possible.
Susan Daniels: Okay, you want your plan, when you send it up to have this tolerance is kind of proposed Is this acceptable.
Susan Daniels: Right, I want to my tolerance is will be plus or minus this or they'll tell you, if they find that agreeable or not.
Susan Daniels: You don't have to wonder whether they'll give you the feedback, but if you don't ask they're probably not going to offer so you've got to be proactive in asking for your tolerances when you're making your plans.
Susan Daniels: And we look at the chat.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: Can I give an example of a non functional solution.
Susan Daniels: accepted or baseline requirements, including solution functional non functional um okay so.
Susan Daniels: Give me a moment I got to resurrect some knowledge.
Susan Daniels: functional solution.
Susan Daniels: it's got to work this way right it's got about all these features and all these capabilities and that's what it's got to do to perform right non functional solutions, if I recall correctly.
Susan Daniels: If I call you might be things that surround it and it might be in an IT world it might be.
Susan Daniels: it's gotta be stable if if i've got a process and implemented it it's got to stay stable it's got to be operational if the downtime can be more than X percent per time period.
Susan Daniels: It has nothing to do with the features and functionality of the solution i've got in place but there's these supporting kind of non functional requirements okay that have to be met as well.
Susan Daniels: If people got other answers to that, I do think there's a slide that comes but that's what's coming to mind at the moment.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: What is the relation between tolerances and management reserve, what is it Tom what is the relationship between tolerances and management reserve.
Susan Daniels: Well, one I want to commend you for being so engaged in thinking ahead and excellent question Okay, that is a that is a well developed question your tolerance is often for performance reporting as you're going through the day to day.
Susan Daniels: of your work, if you have little ups and downs, and you get to the end of your reporting cycle and you're a little bit over budget.
Susan Daniels: But you're within your tolerance, then you're able to say to leadership.
Susan Daniels: on schedule within tolerance on budget within tolerance Okay, which basically says i'm working is fine, I may not be exactly perfect but i'm within my tolerances i'm good.
Susan Daniels: No further explanation required hey right, I can just say within tolerances So where does management reserve comes in minimum income reserve comes in, when your project has burned through not just as tolerances.
Susan Daniels: it's burn through all of his contingency who funds, and now is knocking on the door asking for management's money okay so.
Susan Daniels: tolerances is at the very beginning of being a little off management reserve is way above we've gone through a lot of bad stuff OK, and now we're knocking at the door for help okay with management money, I hope, that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: With those two are related so very sophisticated question Okay, I need to move on, because we're heading towards a break, and I have not moved suits on some of these.
Susan Daniels: But I really wanted to talk heavily about the work breakdown structure i'm.
Susan Daniels: Managing the scope management plan tolerances can technically be modified as you go right on if you're in an agile environment definitely you can adapt scope if you're in a.
Susan Daniels: predictive you know, not so much you'd have to go through formal change control if you're doing increments and you're kind of doing a lay planning to our horizon line, yes, your scope can be updated and clarified as you get closer to that incrementally so um.
Susan Daniels: it's it really depends on the life cycle of the project and what you have negotiated with your sponsors on how you're going to master plan this okay.
Susan Daniels: Whether it's one and done because it's small and can be executed rather directly or whether you're going to build it in increments or whether you're going to really go adaptive and do it in tiny increments and provide feedback and keep getting feedback and adapting as you go.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: How our tolerance levels determine, through expert judgment meetings acceptance um.
Susan Daniels: Good question if you're not familiar with the industry you're not familiar with the company you don't really know the culture of that company of what they find acceptable yes you're going to need to go ask okay kind of what's the norm here um.
Susan Daniels: But typically plus or minus 5% or 10% depending on, you know how big of that number becomes.
Susan Daniels: is acceptable for tolerance, plus or minus five to 10% depends depending on your on your nominator.
Susan Daniels: The denominator of your project when it comes to your schedule is plus or minus one time box okay an hour a day a week okay.
Susan Daniels: So it really it's project specific industry, specific and sometimes even culture specific to your organization, I hope, that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: Alright, so if as an Airbus, these are acronyms you will need to memorize okay ethos which stand for on environmental.
Susan Daniels: environmental factors.
Susan Daniels: i'm sorry guys i'm just all enterprise environmental factors and obama's our organizational process assets.
Susan Daniels: These are things that literally, you have to keep in mind so for your notes okay i'm going to give you a shorthand of the difference between an ethos and an OPA okay ethos.
Susan Daniels: Things that can impact my project.
Susan Daniels: Things in my environment either inside my organization or outside my organization, but things that I need to when I am planning, need to be cognizant of what aware of take into consideration.
Susan Daniels: Oh path okay.
Susan Daniels: Things I can use.
Susan Daniels: Open or organizational process assets, they are things that I can use to make it easier for me to be able to execute my project.
Susan Daniels: When you think of opus one of the best illustrations and an OPA is standard operating procedures if you are new to a company and you've got your.
Susan Daniels: And you're excited to be hired as a project manager, but you don't know how to navigate your organization very well right you're kind of the new guy.
Susan Daniels: One of the things you want to get your hands on our organizational process assets.
Susan Daniels: The entire org structure of that that organization very important right you're going to need that how do I figure out who's who and where I need to go and how this place is organized standard operating procedures.
Susan Daniels: You can find out how to hire TIM staff, how to acquire desktop capabilities for your new team, how to book conference rooms for long periods right, these are organizational process assets things that you need right away to get going ethos are more about.
Susan Daniels: I need to understand the Labor market around me, is it going to be easy to find talent in my area, am I in a major city like jacksonville Florida.
Susan Daniels: Or am I in some small backwater town in the middle of nowhere okay it's going to be a lot harder for me to find local talent, so these sort of environmental factors will impact how I go about building my team right.
Susan Daniels: So these are the things that you have to take into consideration, and they can impact, how you solution right how you build your solution.
Susan Daniels: Are there a lot of regulatory requirements in my industry and are there going to be a lot of requirements relative to permits.
Susan Daniels: And audits and inspections hey that's going to have to be built into my quality plan so we're still at a very much a beginning of.
Susan Daniels: Our work right we've looked at our our team and the things to take into account and building a high performing team.
Susan Daniels: Now is just left the Charter right we just left those charter meetings and we've had a little kickoff to talk about the organization know hey this projects coming.
Susan Daniels: Now you really need to start defining all the work we can't do the work you can't plan it well without understanding environmental factors that are going to impact you with inside the company and outside the company.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: um How does in resource availability different from open like standard operating procedures resource availability is external to you.
Susan Daniels: And i'm an OPA as an asset is a pre existing thing inside the company's pre existing templates it's procedures guidelines its assets that like a sharepoint site desktop capabilities, they are things you can use okay.
Susan Daniels: environmental factors are more non non physical and may not be.
Susan Daniels: Relevant.
Susan Daniels: To currency exchange rate right has nothing to do with an asset within that organization, but it's an environmental factor it's it's external.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so i've got a great video on this so give me a second to pull it over.
Susan Daniels: Here, and we will watch.
Susan Daniels: turn the volume up.
project managers and members of project teams must understand the factors or conditions that may affect project outcomes.
In addition to organizational culture, there are two other items that contribute to a project and how its managed in this topic i'm going to talk about enterprise environmental factors and organizational process assets.
Susan Daniels: Enterprise environmental factors are almost always outside the control of the project team, that is why, being aware, is essential to identifying potential risks and requirements, the term enterprise environments.
Within.
Susan Daniels: The enterprise lines of authority personnel and administrative policies.
Susan Daniels: technology used to manage projects such as databases and scheduling software influencing factors may also originate from the external environment.
Susan Daniels: Examples include government or industry standards conditions in the marketplace that determine consumer attitudes and competition.
Susan Daniels: The economy and the socio political situation of the area in which the project will be carried out and organizations history determines its structure and culture.
Susan Daniels: It also determines the available process assets that can contribute to the success of a project processes and procedures are one category of process assets.
Susan Daniels: This category includes plans created for the project as a whole, as well as specialized plans such as budget and risk response plans.
Susan Daniels: Standard processes, including company policies and processes for product and project life cycles Steve standard procedures, including guidelines work instructions proposal evaluations and performance criteria.
templates including general project tools such as risk templates work breakdown structures and schedule network diagrams.
Susan Daniels: The corporate knowledge base is made up of historical data on projects completed in the past.
Susan Daniels: Organizations often have information stores containing past measurements related to processes products and finances, these are generally held in project files and records, they also store information on past project issues and defects in what are known as lessons learned knowledge bases.
Susan Daniels: hi everybody um we've got a couple of minutes before the hour and I just want to kind of flip through the next couple of slides and touch on the different kinds of tools and techniques that are used in scope.
Susan Daniels: Development of course one of the best places to go is to go look through existing documentation of what already exists and how we got to where we are and.
Susan Daniels: Look at different solution options that may have been considered in the past, I mean really just kind of do some archive looking, as well as referencing existing assets that are available to help me build my project management plan.
Susan Daniels: Particularly I always like to see if we've already got something out on the market is similar and how it was promoted and how look for its basic project design so great place kind of not invent the wheel.
Susan Daniels: Focus groups, sometimes the focus group can tell you how to.
Susan Daniels: build the best product or the best solution, get the right people in the room, and ask the right questions they can be informal focus groups or they can be formal focus groups.
Susan Daniels: If you're not familiar with what a concept of a focus group is i'm not gonna go deep on it today because I really need to stay on pace um.
Susan Daniels: So let's just recognize it, this is if you're not familiar it's something you need to research and go deeper on.
Susan Daniels: questionnaires and surveys just go and ask people okay absolutely.
Susan Daniels: i'll be with you in a minute, with some questions, I just want to get through these different tools.
Susan Daniels: it's just a variety of way of asking Okay, you can do it in a meeting you can do an expert judgment, you can have focus groups formal or you can send out surveys and questionnaires.
Susan Daniels: there's benchmarking go out and look at what's in the market now and.
Susan Daniels: decide whether you're trying to be best in class market parody or you just want to be a low cost producer and just get it done okay so understanding what's out in the market and observing how others are succeeding in trying to.
Susan Daniels: produce a similar result is another way of beginning to build your scope requirements interviews and root decision making, so now you've collected, a lot of these requirements right and now you've got to figure out from the different solution options that we have and the different.
Susan Daniels: Ways of just just want to make sure that i'm where I think I am okay so you've collected, all of this.
Susan Daniels: And now you got to figure out of all the different ways that we go about building it, how do we decide.
Susan Daniels: Well project managers use group decision making techniques, a lot and we talked about 55 dot voting we talked about.
Susan Daniels: You know, Roman voting well another way of voting is can be you try to build consensus Okay, or you can be autocratic about it, where you listen to everybody's input and then one person decides, or you can use something called multi criteria decision analysis.
Susan Daniels: Multi criteria decision analysis is an approach to group decision making.
Susan Daniels: You know what is the top of the hour, you guys have been on for an hour, and I think this might just be a good place to stop I will.
Susan Daniels: pick back up with multifactor decision analysis and types of voting and we'll move into requirements when we get back i'm going to set up the timer and we'll just take a quick break let's get the music going give me a moment.
Susan Daniels: music.
Susan Daniels: we're on break just make a 15 minute break.
Susan Daniels: here.